Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
You know, English stuff, but I'm really tired today and I don't really feel like...
You know what?
Oh! Hi, Seita.
What's up?
I'm doing my show right now and I'm too tired to teach, so you need to do it.
What? Are you serious?
Alright, good night!
Okay, alright. So, today's Maestro Hook is about self-introduction.
I think a lot of Japanese people are not very good at self-introduction.
So, I'm gonna show you a good example of introduction, okay?
So, hi! This is Ikuyo.
I'm from Tokyo.
I like hanging out with my friends at cafes and I'm really into yoga right now.
So yeah, like this.
Show off.
He's showing himself off.
Stand out.
She stands out.
So, Maestro Lines.
Hey! He's trying to show his English off?
Yeah, I think he wants everyone to know like, you know, his English is good.
Look at that girl, you know, in a red dress.
She really stands out.
Oh, yeah. I think she's gonna go to a party tonight.
I think that's it for today, but he's still sleeping.
Seita! Seita! It's over!
Alright. So, I hope you enjoyed this show.
Bye-bye! See you next week!